Hey Joe how are you good Dave how's it
going
better than I deserve sir what's up okay
so I uh I'm 26 years old I have been
dating this girl for about two and a
half years and I'm thinking about buying
gays are you proposing what's about her
thank you oh yes I was wondering if you
had you know you know one of your rule
of thumbs or if you had any advice on
how much somebody in my situation should
spend on an engagement ring
the jewelry store will tell you two
months or three months of your income I
will tell you one month around one month
okay what do you make a year um this
year I'll make between a hundred and one
hundred and ten oh okay she's gonna do
really good then okay um but yeah
definitely no more than that and then no
more than you can pay cash for either
okay yeah I've been saving the cash how
much you got saved I have about thirty
thousand okay yeah that's a little rich
for a ring when you may not
automatically when a and make a hundred
I mean eight eight eight or so is your
monthly income that's a nice nice ring
and let me just tell you my my wife we
were laughing about this week as a
matter of fact because somebody's
talking about diamonds and carats I
can't remember where we were I think was
at this entre leadership event and
anyway we're talking about Sharon got
married on a married Dave Ramsey on a
point to seven point two seven carat
that's a fourth of a carat you can't
even see it it's so freakin small okay
it's in the safe she's got a really big
one now but um but she's our how to tell
you that thirty-three years with me and
so so you know the point is you can get
married with a bubblegum machine ring
right and you only know what that is but
a cheap ring and the there is no
statistical correlation between the size
of the diamond and the success of the
marriage there may actually be an
inverse correlation okay large diamonds
may be a bad bad idea actually but it's
not it's not the end of the world it's
okay to have a nice Rock but don't get
all caught up in that and listen here's
the deal there's nothing has more markup
on it anywhere than jewelry you know
that right oh absolutely I uh
I know a few people that own jewelry
stores and they're gonna give me a good
deal
yeah because you're going to your and
get half if they're giving you a good
deal it's gonna be half of what it would
be sitting in the cabinet okay that's
what it ought to be because there
there's that much room in these things
there is more margin in the furniture
and diamonds most markup of anything we
buys consumers so just huge margin in
that stuff so yeah get you a deal and
and learn a little bit about it in the
process learn about the carrots and the
clarity and the cut and how that all
affects value and learn all that but
don't get under the illusion that
diamonds are an investment because
they're not they really don't go up in
value much I own a bunch of them
actually Sharon owns a bunch of them but
I've bought her several things over the
years that are really really nice but
they are just really really nice they
really have not we've not gone oh would
you look at that the thing that rings
doubled in value now it hasn't it hasn't
and they're just you know it's just
something we buy is something our
culture does so enjoy it and get
something nice that she's going to love
and I would keep it under 10 grand if
I'm in your shoes under 10 grand I
appreciate it thank you so much - thank
you ma'am appreciate the call well done
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
save room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you